this tension between the drive to do
more the acceptance of who we are the
wanting to to show up in the world and
to to give it everything that we've got
and the gratitude for the things that we
already have
yeah well it is a constant tension and I
think you want to ultimately I think you
want to be biased on the the being side
of it I mean certainly if you've
succeeded enough right like if you have
a
if you recognize that you've won the
lottery on some level and you
are in a position now where
there are billions of people who would
consider their prayers answered if they
could trade places with you right and
you you there'll be a time in your life
where
you would give anything to trade places
with who you who you are now right like
when you're you know when you're in your
last months of life and you're
terminally ill or you're you know you've
lost someone very close to you I mean
there's like when you're having when you
have this moment in the sun where
basically you're basically things are
basically going well right
I think it's appropriate to have a
a module in your in your mind which
continually pings you which says like if
you can't enjoy this right like you you
know if this is going to be wasted on
you you're never going to be happy right
like this is the you should be able to
enjoy this part like this this is this
is dessert right dessert has arrived and
you whatever story you have about all
the other things you might do or become
this is really like you know this is a
wonderful life right so can you
can you settle into this at all with
your attention right and if you can't I
think that's the problem to recognize
right like if like if the thing you
should want to become is someone who's
better at
recognizing the beauty of your life
moment to moment right now there's a
paradox there that ultimately has to be
overcome right like the wanting to
become more spiritual wanted wanted to
become a great meditator I wanted to
become enlightened that's you know a
a knot that that gets untied but
it's a fairly you know refined one
um
but
it is it's just totally appropriate to
recognize this mismatch between
what is objectively true of your life by
reference by comparison to anything else
that is on the menu and the general
mediocrity of your
way of being you know just the feeling
I mean and so this is again this is this
is dual down to you not in big chunks
but in moments right like this is not
like the grand plan like okay I got my
calendar out this month is going to be
about X and now I'm going to nail X
right it's much more
a thousand lessons over the course of a
day right like like you have to just be
attentive to
moments where you miss it
and moments where you and then and then
just recognizing that it's invade it's
available now right like you were a
moment ago you were
tied in a knot somehow for some reason
you know things were awkward or weird
and then and then and now you're back
right so like I was I was coming to this
interview
um and I was I was late I was 15 minutes
late you know and and I hate being late
for whatever reason and
um so I'm kind of rushing to get out of
the house and you know my wife has got
her own day ahead of her and she's
rushing to get out of the house and
we're sort of ping-ponging around each
other and we're kind of missing each
other and in and out of the bathroom in
and out of the closet and and
I I say goodbye to her but it was a sort
of a goodbye like you know I've just
completely missed her like this
beautiful woman who I've decided to
spend my life with and like like where
she's now just a basically an obstacle I
have to navigate around so this would be
you know 30 seconds earlier than I would
otherwise be if I just took a moment to
recognize how beautiful my life is right
so I missed I missed her I miss her I
miss her I missed her and then at the
penultimate moment as I'm grabbing my
keys I'm like
oh here she is right and so I just stop
her I give her a kiss and then I leave
right and it's just the difference
between finding that moment and not is
enormous right and it's just it's it's
like the area under the Curve
could still suck a lot from it's like in
the beginning you might only have 20
moments like that a day right but the
difference between being someone who
never gets it clearly right and it never
truly punctuates his busyness and
ambition and disappointment and
everything every other you know module
that's been installed with just clear
you know
clear contact with the beauty and
sacredness of the present moment
that difference is is enormous and once
you have those those punctate moments
and again this is a meditation by
another name
then you can have a hundred and then you
can have a thousand and then and then
then the character of your life can more
and more resemble
the true Virtues Of Being
even when you're still becoming and even
when you have the whole apparatus of
you've got employees you've got a
calendar you've got slack is open all
day it's like it's all that's happening
you can still be someone who's
basically already happy right you're
like you're not leaning forward
so much and when you do our leaning
forward
part of you recognizes okay what's this
about like like you have a kind of
mindfulness alarm that goes off when
you're when you're obviously expecting
to become Happy by the next thing
right
rather than be truly taken in by that
dream
part of you knows okay wait a minute
like just said just correct your posture
a little bit like you know that no
matter how good this dinner is it's just
going to be a dinner right and then
you're going to be too full and then
you're going to wish you hadn't eaten
all that and then you then you're gonna
find it hard to sleep and then and
that so like you you know that there's
it can't be a matter of of reaching and
grabbing and and fully
uh satisfying your desire again and
again and again as a as a
a way to finally become happy there's
got you have to find locate your
satisfaction more and more in just the
in in the state of being that is already
here that's preceding the next change
your debt your happiness can't be
ultimately a matter of changing
experience it has to be a matter of
recognizing
the nature of experience now
that it can be you know
very easy to have a cynical take on that
and say okay well it's easy for you to
say a rich white guy who for whom
everything's going great and nothing bad
has yet happened and the worst thing
that happened to you was on Twitter and
so go [__] yourself uh but no first of
all many bad things have happened I know
what it's like to lose someone close to
me I know what it's like to worry that
your your kid is really sick I know what
it's like to be waiting for the MRI of
like like there's all these moments
where
you know even even the luckiest among us
know what it's like to to live in in
with real uncertainty and the knowledge
that
you know ultimately
every bad thing some version of every
bad thing is going to happen I mean even
if you're the luckiest and healthiest
and richest you know then you're just
going to be sitting by the phone you
know hearing that all your friends have
died right like if you live to be 120 in
perfect health you know you're you're
Peter attia and you've you've uh you
know you're still doing kettlebells at
120 which I hope you keep them in yeah
yeah I hope you are Peter and Andrew
um then you're just going to be getting
you know
voicemails and texts and whatever else
exists at that point hearing that all
these people you loved have disappeared
right so no one gets out of here without
real a real encounter with with Greek
level tragedy and
the question is is it possible to have a
mind
that can Embrace that with Equanimity
and compassion and love and
tranquility
or do you just have to to pretend none
of that's going to happen
the normal mode is to to try to be lucky
enough
so that you can pretend hard enough and
long enough that none of that [__]
applies to me right like I'm just gonna
you know I'm gonna I'm gonna stay
healthy for as long as I can stay
healthy I'm not going to think about
cancer until somebody has cancer like
it's like I'm just I'm gonna
extract as much pleasure as I possibly
can in the moment and you know look that
Bugatti over there is mine right you
know so it's like that's
the at best that's impermanent right
even if that was as satisfying as as
someone could pretend and we actually
know it's not and you can know that from
the inside the more you have those
experiences the
it's impermanent you know I mean it's
like a certain point Andrew Tate is
going to be the the 80 year old with bad
tattoos right like it's just not it's
like it's it's not it doesn't scale like
like that you need you need a another
gear and
there are many names for this I mean
wisdom is one name spirituality
um
Enlightenment Awakening
um meditation all of these Concepts you
know psychedelic experiences all of
these tools and concepts are are
triangulating on a part of the map where
one's well-being isn't contingent upon
changes in experiences there's a
recognition
that is possible about the nature of of
conscious life itself that is fulfilling
giving ourselves a good enough reason to
just be here in the present moment yeah
in other news this episode is brought to
you by element element is the way that
I've started my day every single morning
for over three years now it is the best
hydration drink that I've ever found
there's no gluten no fillers no
artificial junk or any other BS it
tastes phenomenal that orange salt
flavor is absolutely outstanding it'll
help to regulate your appetite it'll
curb Cravings it'll improve brain
function and it means that you don't
need to have a coffee first thing in the
morning your adenosine system that
caffeine acts on isn't even active for
the first 90 minutes of the day but salt
acts on your adrenal system an element
contains a science-backed electrolyte
ratio of sodium potassium and magnesium
they also have a no BS no questions
asked refund policy where you can buy
100 risk-free and if you do not like it
for any reason they'll give you your
money back and you don't even need to
return the Box head to drink lmnt.com
modern wisdom to get a free sample pack
of all eight flavors with your first box
that's drink
lmnt.com
modern wisdom